[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who loves
to see
dick in the batcave and i'm not talking
about nightwing
we are back with some brand new plot
details on the batman
and in this video we're going to be
going over not only them but also the
first look at the bat suit in the
upcoming flash movie
there's a ton of easter eggs in this
image and throughout the breakdown we'll
be going over everything you need to
know about it
there might be some spoilers here so if
you don't want anything ruined then i
recommend that you christian bale
yes we are scraping the barrel of puns
because
we've been reporting on this for about
two years now but if you still enjoy
them then smash the thumbs up button
and subscribe for videos like this each
and every day without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the video
okay so the first thing i want to talk
about is some brand new plot details
that were posted on subreddit dce leaks
you want to skip ahead to the michael
keaton part of the video then
time codes will be linked below now i
tend to stay away
as much as possible from reporting on
leaks from reddit because anyone can
post them
but this kind of corroborates things
that i've heard behind the scenes
the first point is that one of batman's
fight scenes includes him taking down
three thugs with an empty pistol
it goes on to say that this iteration of
the caped crusader is extremely violent
and his gloves have blood on them after
one of the fight scenes
the post even says that he punches
someone so hard that he almost breaks
his wrist at one point
and it definitely seems like the kind of
thing that lines up with what we've seen
in the trailer
it also says batman experiments with a
lot of different gadgets
which are in various stages of
development he has battle ranks a
grapple gun
and can deploy smoke which comes out
from pipes under his wrists
the batmobile itself looks very diy and
even the bat bike is somewhat just a
repurposed motorcycle
now he also has a watch slash screen
which he uses as a gps
tracker and also to communicate with
alfred
now this seems legit because it's what
we can make out on the costume
so i'm i'm gonna guess that this is
definitely happening in the movie
take one off for legitimate spoiler man
i always get them right i told you now
there was also an action figure shown
recently
in which we could see the grapnel gun
and ammo for it which
will be using the darts on his gauntlets
now speaking of alfred the post states
that he and bruce have a very rocky
father and son-like relationship and
that they have multiple arguments
throughout the film
as alfred doesn't approve of bruce being
batman he apparently pesters him about
every little mistake
including the time bruce almost killed
someone get over it alfred you're
starting to sound like
someone on youtube that says batman
doesn't kill all the time
now ignoring all that this is very
similar to what we see in earth one
which the movie is apparently meant to
be heavily based upon
in that alfred is sort of a mentor that
teaches him combat skills
and he becomes paramount in helping
bruce to carve out a legacy as the dark
knight
the post states that robert's batman
voice is very low
it's almost like he's whispering which
is something that we can hear from the
trailers
after he smashes that dude's face in
like you should smash the like button
now the most interesting point probably
in the list is that it states that bruce
is extremely mentally ill
and that he's actually on medication he
of course saw his parents murdered in
front of him as a child
and likely suffers from ptsd because of
this he also has to deal with the
anxiety that comes from that night
and batman as a character is very much
about trying to formulate control in a
world of chaos
batman was created by bruce as a way to
control his fear
in order to not let his fear control him
i think that this is a side of bruce's
personality that's definitely worth
exploring
and there are several avenues of mental
health that the film can look into
these include depression schizophrenia
and multiple personality disorder
according to grace randolph warner bros
are a bit worried about marketing toys
for the movie
because it could be seen as exploiting
mental health issues
the joker of course didn't have any
action figures to go with the film
so it'll be interesting to see how they
handle it but as far as the character's
study goes
i think it's a really great thing for
them to be tackling bruce is someone
who's going through a dark knight
crisis and it's just so bad and it just
makes the character
way more complex and interesting now
apparently barbara gordon is mentioned a
few times in the film
but she's never shown i actually think
that she might pop up in the gcpd
spin-off series
and you might remember that ceo of
feminism joss whedon
was working on a film for her before it
was scrapped
so they will likely take the character
in a brand new direction
and i think this universe is the perfect
way to go the post also states goth corp
is part of gotham
and this of course ties in with mr
freeze it would be ice to see him
but currently we don't know if he's
gonna be in the film or not
now apparently the riddler also has
several flashbacks to when he was a
teenager
namely when his parents were killed and
the final showdown between him and the
batman will take place at an orphanage
we know that one was spotted whilst
filming was happening so this does seem
likely
if both characters are dealing with the
trauma caused by their parents deaths
then i think that this will be an
amazing place to take the movie
and i would absolutely love it if this
is where they go head to head
now lastly the post says that the film
will be r-rated
and this is something i think will be
very fitting for the character
judging by the tone of the trailer i
can't see this being below an
m or a 15 in the uk and joker has
already shown that you can have big
comic book movies that don't cater to
all ages
and still make more money than bruce
wayne i don't know if that joke works
anymore but
i still remember when batman was a
millionaire as i'm old
now with most posts on the internet
especially about batman
there's been so much garbage floating
about that it's
difficult to discern what's true what
isn't i'm looking at you we got this
covered
i'm sure most of us remember the post
from february about pattinson having sex
with zoe kravitz on the batmobile
and how much bs that was wait you don't
remember
well let's read it now i'm working on
the set of the batman
so in about a week or so all media will
go after him for what he and zoe did on
the set of the batman last week
we me and a lot of workers with matt
reeves court robert pattinson and zoe
kravitz having sex on the batmobile prop
it sounds like a bit of a porno this
it's probably one of the worst things
i've ever saw in my career now come on
mate they're not that ugly
matt was so furious he interrupted he
interrupted them
excuse me guys can you stop having sex
on the batmobile
and that's not all so he took a
pregnancy test
and she is pregnant imagine it's just
just just sounds like ralph wagon from
the simpsons when he's talked about how
the baby looked at him anyway
since october robert and zoe started
dating in secret
we knew about it as soon as we saw them
together after work
she recently divorced her husband though
i'm purely disgusted by the act doesn't
sound it makes you keep banging on about
it
all i know is that reeves is so furious
that he might not do the batman two and
three as he planned and let someone else
direct
mate he's getting paid millions of
pounds you can i'll watch robert
pattinson and zoe kravitz have sex all
day
if it makes us a millionaire but anyway
he literally told patterson
you are the most entitled narcissistic
actor i've ever worked with
you go back to work probably said wipe
yourself down we finished filming in
march
and then we are done i don't ever want
to work with you after this film
he even said he refuses to do reshoots
if they will be needed
i don't know what they're going to do
now but they are trying to keep this
situation unleashed before the media
make it official we had that it's been
posted posted back in february but uh
i've got no idea how
zoey kravitz still isn't showing that
she's pregnant but never mind
scoop there for you guys just in case
you didn't know now the next part of the
video
we're going to be talking about i'm
sorry i'm really sorry about that i just
had to cover it because it's one of the
funniest rumors i've ever read now
the next part of the video we're going
to be talking about the first look at
michael keaton's bat suit from the flash
on friday director annie muscati posted
a close-up of the symbol with some
strawberry jam on it
and this is clearly the same as the suit
that he had for returns
now the movie is apparently going to be
based on flashpoint and in case you
haven't read that book then here's a
quick breakdown
barry goes back in time to save his
mother from being killed
but in doing so the butterfly effect
creates a shock wave in time that
changes many events
for example superman lands outside
kansas and is captured by the government
atlantis and their mascara go to war and
bruce is killed in the alley instead of
his parents
his father thomas becomes batman and
though i can't see
keaton being anyone but bruce it does
introduce this idea of alternate
batman's
flash managed to correct the timeline in
the book and this was apparently wiped
out
and it allowed dc to start the new 52
and what's strange is that
this image looks very similar to the
comedian's badge from watchmen
in dc rebirth this was found in the
batcave and the flash ended up going
back to the source
which is where he discovered thomas
wayne's timeline was still active
and it was just in an alternate
dimension so it's going to be
interesting to see if this is hinting
towards that
but what it is hinting towards is that
wb are definitely marketing this as a
batman movie
over being one with the flash the first
set photos we saw were of wayne manor
and the first look is a batman so yeah
maybe ezra
maybe you're gonna have to go up into
those wb offices and choke someone out
now i have heard that the studio is
aware that this incident will cause some
issues
when they go to promote the film so
they're leaning more heavily into the
batman as
he's not only more bankable but keaton
is way less controversial it's also
going to be interesting to see how they
market aquaman
in light of constant things about amber
heard coming out and it seems like wb
are gonna have to play it very carefully
as let's face it they're not the most
popular studio right now
either way though i'd of course love to
hear your thoughts on the point
especially the batmobile story and make
sure you comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
show on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the phase three mcu box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the video
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
spoilers if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of sweet tooth which
will be linked on screen right now it's
a great dc book and also a great netflix
show
so it's definitely worth watching if you
want to know more without the way thanks
for sitting until the end of the video
i'll see you next time and you take care
yourself
peace